[Music]
tuition has been growing fast
at america's public universities
in-state tuition
at public four-year schools increased
from three thousand eight hundred
dollars in 1990
to more than ten thousand dollars that's
approaching three times the cost
after adjusting for inflation and as
students logged into class from home in
the pandemic
few schools offered discounts president
biden
wants to make it more affordable to get
a degree
public college colleges and universities
be tuition free for families earning
less than 125
000 the president and his allies argue
that the federal government should do
more to help students
but research says that federal programs
meant to help students pay for college
have actually made higher education more
expensive
[Music]
the story begins on the balance sheets
of public four-year schools
like the university of oregon in 2020
the university spent more than 975
million dollars on operations
that includes wages for professors and
administrators
and upkeep on facilities a school can
pay for some of its spending
by drawing on donations that are stored
in an endowment
but endowments often have spending
limitations
so the more important revenue streams
for public colleges
tend to be state funding and student
tuition
but what happens with the former greatly
affects the latter
josh mitchell covers economics for the
wall street journal what's happened over
the years is that burden of paying for
college has shifted from
state taxpayers to the families
themselves
and so now we're seeing that more and
more schools are relying on tuition to
get a bulk of their funding
during recessions many states opt to cut
funding for universities
the lost revenue is made up by raising
tuition or admitting more
students especially ones from out of
state or overseas
this gives public schools like the
university of oregon an incentive
to expand their profile to attract not
only in-state students
but also non-residents who have to pay
higher out-of-state tuition fees
so they bolster their academic programs
and they add recreational perks like
gyms
and rock climbing walls you know if you
can make your campus more attractive
by investing in these types of things
that students like to do and make it a
fun environment like a disney world
environment
more students are going to want to go
there more students are going to want to
apply and therefore the school is going
to have
the power to raise tuition and students
will be willing to pay
these amenities are making prices rise
but there are deeper factors at play
concerns about tuition and the high cost
of college have been around
since 1900 and they really started to
rise in the 40s and 50s
and so congress comes in and they say
okay well we want to help people
pay for college we'll do it through
student loans
the federal government started financing
the college system when lyndon johnson
signed the higher education act of 1965.
if we reject learning we render
ourselves dead to the past
and lost to the future since then
generations of leaders have approved
changes to the act to influence how
money
flows into the college system when
congress created this program
under the higher education act it gave
schools an incentive to raise their
prices
because think about it each student now
has a voucher to pay for college
so this became a really big way for
schools to make money
um through student loans and so it gave
kind of this perverse incentive for
schools to raise their costs
instead of competing on price a lot of
schools actually learned
they could actually charge more not less
if they could convince their students
that they were prestigious
for example say a student from
california receives pell grants and
loans from the federal government
they're free to spend that money at the
school of their choice
some students opt for an in-state
education
but others can be lured by an attractive
amenity
or a key research program and they can
take those dollars
out of state this incentivizes schools
to spend more on programs and facilities
and ultimately charge more for tuition
but those increased
costs affect every enrolled student
including those who are in state
dr gray gordon at the federal reserve
bank of richmond
has studied what makes tuition prices
rise so rapidly
what we found is that the main drivers
of college tuition inflation
are demand side factors that is things
that increase
willingness of students to pay for
school dr gordon and his colleague
studied the factors that increased
average college tuition between 1987
and 2010. they found that increases in
federal financial aid were responsible
for more than
54 percent of all tuition price rises
observed in that period
in particular a tweak to federal
policies
first seen in 1993 greatly contributed
to this increase
before 1993 only subsidized loans
existed so
those were given out to students with
demonstrated need
but in 1993 the program was expanded so
now students who didn't qualify for
subsidized loans
now qualified for unsubsidized loans
this greatly increased the ability of
students to pay for school
and ultimately led to tuition increases
but the federal government isn't the
only factor at play here
more parents are willing to spend on
their children's education
because college graduates earn 84
percent more than high school graduates
over their careers this earnings premium
has risen over time
and it's making tuition prices rise too
so what can be done to rein in costs for
students
leaders in the private and public
sectors have offered different paths
forward
most notably president biden experts
tell the journal that biden's
tuition-free proposal as written
would have mixed effects on tuition
price increases
his call to double the amount given as a
grant will give students more money to
spend at any college in the country
this could increase student demand for
higher education which would push
prices up further but the plan also
calls for the federal government to
cover 75 percent of in-state tuition for
qualifying students
if states agree to pay the rest this
could calm some of the competition
between public colleges
for out-of-state students an analysis
conducted by georgetown university
professor
anthony carnevale did find that biden's
proposal
would pay for itself we know
through a fairly elaborate
set of economic analysis of the biden
plan
if we put the money down now 10 years
the program will pay for itself
but dr carnavali says the problem of
rising tuition can't be addressed with
government policy alone
the private sector has also proposed
ways to train workers without a
four-year degree
google for example offers a six-month
certificate that can stand
in for a four-year degree in certain it
roles
and thousands of universities are
collaborating with websites like
coursera
to provide new inexpensive learning
options
experts say that a consensus has emerged
costs for college are too high
and in a world shaken by the coronavirus
and an uncertain economic recovery
parents and students are increasingly
asking is this all worth it
[Music]
you